It's still 360p!
It is!
But I did the output!
Oh no...
But
I did the output!
Big Mac!
No!
What do I do?
360p stream and sing old songs.
Now I'm tired.
Because I'm tired of this bullshit!
What the hell?
Does it sound okay at least?
People who watch the Vaan are going to be so confused.
I can say buddy on Bandwidth.
It sounds okay?
You sound fine?
Let's do a test song and see how it sounds then.
Maybe.
What would be...
I think I know a good song for this...
For this...
Hold on.
Let's see if I can find it.
Oh!
I found it!
Okay, I'm gonna sing this song.
Oh!
I forgot to turn on the...
Okay.
I'm gonna make sure...
This is a test to see if the audio gets all wacky too.
It just jumped?
Oh!
Wait!
I don't wanna sing this then!
Ai-yai-yai!
Where's my samurai?
I'm a search for a man All across Japan Just to find, to find my samurai Someone who is strong But still a little shy Yes, I need, I need my samurai Ai-yai!
I'm your little bunch of fly Green, black, and blue Make the colors in the sky Ai-yai-yai!
I'm your little bunch of...
I've been searching through the woods And high up on the hills Just to find, to find my samurai Someone who won't regret To keep me in his net Yes, I need, I need my samurai Ai-yai-yai!
I'm your little bunch of fly Green, black, and blue Make the colors in the sky Ai-yai-yai!
Ai-yai-yai!
Where's my samurai?
Oh, I don't know this part.
Butterfly.
Smile, DK.
Ai-yai-yai!
I'm your little bunch of fly Green, black, and blue Make the colors in the sky Ai-yai-yai!
I'm your little bunch of fly Green, black, and blue Make the colors in the sky Ai-yai
-yai!
Make the colors in the sky Ai-yai-yai!
Ai-yai
-yai!
Where's my samurai?
Song for 360p!
But now I'm in 1080p!
The effect is ruined.
Ai-yai-yai!
I'm your little butterfly Green, black, and blue Make the colors in the sky
Am I actually...
Oh, gosh.
Okay, well...
Welcome, everybody!
Ai...
It's awkward now.
Because the start of the stream is weird.
Now...
I'm watching in 360p.
Okay, good.
Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome.
Welcome.
I manually set you to 140p.
144p.
I just can't see more than 480p.
I don't believe that.
The start of all your streams are weird.
Shut up.
Yeah.
I drank some coffee.
And I was like...
Because I just did a meet and greet at a convention.
And now I'm like...
Well...
What do I do to burn all this energy off?
Why not do a crazy karaoke?
So...
I'm just gonna sing whatever I want.
And...
Burn the Zoomy energy.
Yeah!
I'll do it until I'm tired.
And...
Isn't it like 10pm?
It's like 11pm.
And I had coffee.
For the...
For the meet and greet.
Because I had to be...
I had to be energetic and excited to see people.
Of course.
So...
Sing and dance.
I don't know.
What to do.
What's another one?
What's another song?
Oh my gosh.
Now I did Butterfly.
That was Butterfly from Smile DK.
That's...
From DDR.
DDR.
But now I'm like...
Should I do like...
I don't know.
I saw some people being like...
Oh.
Guess I won't go to sleep now.
Crazy Frog!
Okay.
I'll do all the...
I'll do all the crazy songs.
And then we'll do...
Is that even SuperBallet?
See!
Oh my gosh.
I hope you're having fun.
Wait.
Who does a Crazy Frog?
Crazy Frog.
Jingle Bells?
Wait.
DDR songs only.
Axel F?
Okay.
I don't know.
Who's going to pull this off?
Okay.
I'll do all the crazy songs.
And then I'll do the slow songs to wind us down, right?
Oh.
How does this go?
Ding.
This is the Crazy Frog!
This is the crazy frog!
I never knew Axl Phantom...
I never knew that this song had...
Wait, I kind of want to hear what the person sounds like.
In KaraFunk, you can hear what the person...
Okay, here.
Let's see.
Let's listen to the lead person real quick.
Okay.
There we go!
That was fun.
That was good.
Good suggestion, everybody.
I feel crazy right now.
It sounded perfect.
Thank you.
Somebody scream!
It's like my favorite sample ever.
Scatman!
I think it's just the 20 gifted.
I'm the Scatman!
It's actually worse than the song.
Everybody's saying it's the Scatman stutters, but he doesn't ever stutter when he sings.
But when you don't know what I'm going to tell you now, that the stutter and the scat is the same thing.
Yo, I'm the Scatman!
Where's the Scatman?
I'm the Scatman!
Why should we be lazy and unapologetically heathen?
And who would change you with a season if they could?
The state of the condition insults my intuitions and it only makes me crazy in the heart like the wood.
Everybody stutters one way or the other.
So check out my message to you.
As a matter of fact, don't let nothing hold you back.
If the Scatman can do it, bother who can you?
Oh brother, say that man.
I'm the Scatman!
Everybody stutters one way or the other.
So check out my message to you.
As a matter of fact, don't let nothing hold you back.
If the Scatman can do it, bother who can you?
I hear a little ask of the many of Scat...
Whoa.
Sleeping the saints and we weeping cause things are gone dead.
Haven't had the chance to be bored.
I'm the Scatman!
Ba da lap.
Wee ba ba ba da bum.
Ba ba ba da bum.
Ski-bee dee dib-a-dee dum-dum dum.
Yum dum dum dum.
Ski-bee dee dib-a-dee yum-dum-dum-dum.
That was the scat man.
With the scat plan.
Wait... maybe not.
Any openings from Full Metal Panic?
I appreciate you.
I think I only know one...
One Full Metal Panic song.
Mambo No.
5!
Oh my god.
Why is multiple people requesting?
I can do it.
Mambo No.
5.
I don't plan on doing...
Here, let me write the Full Metal Panic.
For later.
I don't plan on only just doing Japanese songs or English songs.
So, you know...
Um...
This is certainly nailing the caffeine high vibe.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so excited.
Mambo No.
5!
Oh, ladies and gentlemen.
This is Mambo No.
5.
One, two, three, four, five.
Everybody in the car.
So come on, let's ride.
To the liquor store around the corner.
The boys say they want some gin and juice.
But I really don't wanna...
Be a buzz.
Like I had last week, I must stay deep.
Cause talk is cheap.
I like Angela, Pamela, Sandra and Rita.
And as I continue, you know you're getting sweeter.
What can I do?
I really beg you, my lord.
To me, flirting is just like a sport.
Anything's fly, it's all good.
Let me jump in and send in the trumpet.
A little bit of Monica in my life.
A little bit of Erica by my side.
A little bit of Rita's all I need.
A little bit of Tina.
She knows what I see.
A little bit of Sandra in the sun.
A little bit of Mary all night long.
A little bit of Jessica, here I am.
A little bit of you makes me your man.
Jump up and down.
Move it all around.
Shake your head to the sound.
Put your hands on the ground.
Take one step left and one step right.
One to the front and one to the side.
Clap your hands once.
Clap your hands twice.
And if you look like this, then you're doing it right.
A little bit of Monica in my life.
A little bit of Erica by my side.
A little bit of Rita's all I need.
A little bit of Tina's what I see.
A little bit of Sandra in the sun.
A little bit of Mary all night long.
A little bit of Jessica, here I am.
A little bit of you makes me your man.
A little bit of Monica in my life.
A little bit of Erica by my side.
A little bit of Rita's all I need.
A little bit of Tina's what I see.
A little bit of Sandra in the sun.
A little bit of Mary all night long.
A little bit of Jessica, here I am.
A little bit of you makes me your man.
I do all to fall in love with a girl like you.
Cause you can't run and you can't hide.
You and me gonna touch the sky.
Cause
I'm haunting you guys, you know.
Mambo No.
5.
The lyrics to that are a little...
That's like every Vtuber.
You know, it's just like...
I was scrolling and I didn't expect to come by Yubito.
Hello!
Hello, hello.
She's still doing meme songs throwing in my hat for...
Hey...
Like...
What?
Oh, Numa Numa!
I don't know how to sing it though.
Okay.
What language is that song in?
Because...
I feel...
Like I'm gonna butcher it.
Romanian.
I'm so sorry.
I'll do the Disney version.
What?
There's a Disney version?
No way.
Wait, what's it called?
Hold on.
Also, what song did you mean, Nano?
Like...
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I said hey.
What's going on?
He-Man song!
What is that song called?
My he.
My ya-hoo.
My ya-ha.
My ya-ha-ha.
My ya-hee.
My ya-hoo.
My ya-ha.
My ya-ha-ha.
My ya-hee.
My ya-hoo.
My ya-ha.
My ya-hee.
My ya-hoo.
My ya-ha.
My ya-ha-ha.
My ya-hee.
I'm so sorry.
I want to play, but it's just me, just me, just me, just me, just me, just me, what can I do, my love, to meet you?
I'm afraid of your eyes.
I want to play, but it's just me, just me, just me, just me, what can I do, my love, to meet you?
I'm calling you.
I'm waiting.
I'm saying.
I'm sorry.
Now.
Hello.
A little pause.
I'm here.
I'm Picasso, I'm David.
And I'm floating.
But I don't know anything.
I want to play, but it's just me, just me, just me, just me, just me, what can I do, my love, to meet you?
I'm afraid of your eyes.
I'm afraid of the search.
I want to play.
But it's just me, just me, just me, just me, just me, just me I'm afraid of your eyes.
My youth, My joy, My beauty, My ability, My passion, My a hundred۔ I'm scared of your eyes.
I'm calling you.
Just me, just me, just me, just me, just me, just me, just me, just me, just me, just me, just me I'm asking for your love.
Maya ha ha, maya hi, maya hu, maya ha
Vresa vresa, numa numa ye, numa numa ye Numa numa numa ye, ti putausi, drago sam di te Me omitaste o kitai ye Vresa vresa, numa numa ye, numa numa ye Numa numa numa ye, ti putausi, drago sam di te Me omitaste o kitai ye Oh, I forgot to put the setlist.
Sorry, that was...
Oh, drago...
I think I spelled that right.
The music video for that is crazy.
Oh my god, because it's saying aqua!
Oh my god, what if they have erotic on here too?
That was amazing!
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I think I really butchered that.
Am I in the 2000s?
I'm sure Romanians are happy.
I'm sure Romanians are asleep.
What was the song?
What was the...
Can you do tequila?
Spanish song...
Brujeria?
One of the songs Iron Mouse sings.
Oh my gosh, I don't even know it though.
What's the...
What is that one?
What's it called?
The Parent Trap song.
Wait, I don't know that one either.
They have a wonderful energy.
Thank you!
Oh, what's going on?
Is that what it's called?
What's going on?
I actually don't...
You know what?
I think I don't know what that song is.
Is this it?
I wonder.
Four non-blondes.
Oh wait.
I don't think this is it.
Four blondes?
I don't think that's it.
Wait, four blondes.
Wait, that's it?
Oh gosh, I don't know this song at all.
Oh wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think...
Why is there four...
Oh.
Wait, let me try this one.
Four non-blondes.
Why are they not blonde?
Yeah, this is more like it.
This is more like it.
Yeah, yeah.
Years ago my life...
Trying to get out that...
Big hill of hope.
For a destination.
Am I singing it right?
Who cares?
I quickly realized quickly when I knew I should.
That the world was made up of this brotherhood of man.
For whatever that means.
I don't know.
And so I cry sometimes when I'm lying in bed.
Just to get all out what's in my head.
And I'm...
I'm feeling...
A little peculiar.
It's got a weird phasing, it does.
And so I wake in the morning and I step outside.
And I take a deep breath and I get real high.
And I scream...
Oh, I scream from the top of my lungs.
What's going on?
And I say...
Hey, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey, yeah, yeah.
I said hey.
What's going on?
And I say...
Hey, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey, yeah, yeah.
I said hey.
What's going on?
And
I try.
Oh my god do I try.
I try all the time.
And I pray, oh my God, do I pray.
I pray every single day for a revolution.
And so I cry sometimes when I'm lying in bed just to get it all, what's in my head.
And I'm feeling a little peculiar.
And so I wake in the morning and I step outside.
And I take a deep breath and I get real high.
And I scream from the top of my lungs, what's going on?
And I say, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
I say, hey.
What's going on?
And I say, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
I say, hey.
What's going on?
And I say, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
I say, hey.
Hey!
What's going on?
And I say, hey, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, hey, yeah, yeah.
I said, hey!
What's going on?
Twenty-five years and my life is still trying to get off that great big hill.
Of hope for a destination.
Guys,
Joy Tom Tom, thank you for the double 50 gifted dick.
Did I say that right?
Oh my gosh.
You're the greatest ever do it.
Fast Car by Tracy Chapman.
What's that one?
Fast Car.
I don't know if I know it.
Let me hear it.
Duvet by Duvet.
Let me add it.
Duvet.
It's such a beautiful voice.
Oh, I think I know this one.
We need some Cascada, too.
Mahjong tunes.
Wait, do I know this one?
You've got a fast car.
I wanna take it to anywhere.
Maybe we can make a deal.
Maybe.
Oh my god, look at this.
I don't know if I know it well enough, though.
Starting from zero, got nothing to lose.
Maybe we'll make a deal.
I don't know it well enough.
I'm sorry.
I think I know maybe the...
Fast Car.
I don't know it, though.
Maybe I know the chorus.
You've got a fast car.
I've got a plan to get us out of here.
You've been working at a convenience store.
I don't know.
I'm so sorry.
I know the song, but I don't know the pacing well enough.
I tried.
I tried!
Okay, back to...
2000 eras.
And I'll do BoA next.
I still hear your voice when you sleep next to me.
I still feel your touch in my dreams.
Forgive me my weakness, but I don't know why.
Without you, it's hard to survive.
Cause every time we touch, I get this feeling.
And every time we kiss, I swear I could fly.
Can't you feel my heartbeat fast?
I want this to last.
Need you by my side.
Cause every time we touch, I feel the static.
And every time we kiss, I reach for the sky.
Can't you hear my heartbeat so?
I can't let you go.
Want you in my life.
Oh
gosh, I'm eating.
Your arms are my castle.
Your heart is my sky.
May wipe away tears that I cry.
The good and the bad times, we've been through them all.
You make me rise when I fall.
Cause every time we touch, I get this feeling.
And every time we kiss, I swear I could fly.
Can't you hear my heartbeat fast?
I want this to last.
Need you by my side.
Cause every time we touch, I feel the static.
And every time we kiss, I reach for the sky.
Can't you hear my heartbeat so?
I can't let you go.
Want you in my life.
I
was like half chewing my food while singing that.
Every
time we kiss, I swear I could fly.
Yeah!
That was every time we touch.
Oh my gosh, I wonder if there's any erotic on here.
No, there's not.
How sad.
Anything, anything by Dramarama, onegai shimasu.
Anything, anything.
Mamma mia.
Hold on, let me do... Captain Jack!
Yo!
I wonder if that's on here.
Hold on, I'll write it down.
Captain Jack.
What was that?
Anything, anything.
Okay, let me check Captain Jack.
I will do Boa, don't worry.
I will.
Ayo, Captain Jack!
What was the song?
There was one song in DDR by Captain Jack I used to do all the time.
I wonder... what's this one?
Oh, thank you for... thank you, Cheliax.
Ayo, Captain Jack!
Bring me back to the railroad track!
Into the railroad track!
Run along with Captain Jack!
I don't remember this song at all.
Oh, shit.
Run... Yes!
Dream a dream!
Oh my gosh, how'd you know?
Oh my god, that's the song I used to do all the time!
Left, right, right, left.
Run along with Captain Jack.
I don't know this song at all.
I wonder if they have dream a dream.
Dream a dream.
Ayo, Captain Jack!
Bring me back to the railroad track!
Give me a gun in my hand!
I wanna be a shooting man!
Left, right, left.
The military step.
The Air Force rep.
The 17 is the best.
Oh, shit.
Go le... oh... left, go right, go left, take a step, go left, go right, go left!
To
me!
We are running to the railroad...
What is this song?
Company attention!
Forward!
I wanna be a drinking man!
Left, right, left.
The military step.
The Air Force rep.
The 17 is the best.
To the left!
Left, go right, go pick up the step, go left, go right, go left!
To
the railroad track.
Run along with Captain Jack.
Left, right, right, left.
Hey yo, Captain Jack.
Bring me back to the railroad track.
Give me a woman in my hand.
Bring me a woman in
my hand.
The military step.
The Air Force rep.
The 17 is the best.
Forward march!
We are running to the railroad track.
Run along with Captain Jack.
Run into the peace camp bag.
Right,
right, left.
Right, right, left.
I never knew that it cussed in that song.
I never even knew!
I like the other one.
What was it?
Anything?
Men Phantom Reel.
Let's see.
Someone was watching the panel today.
Thank you.
Let's see.
I don't know if they have it.
What's the Mamma Mia song they have?
Mamma Mia.
Cotton Eye Joe?
What is this?
What is this theme all of a sudden?
Please Cotton Eye Joe.
Okay.
Cotton Eye Joe.
Why?
This is the worst karaoke ever.
And then I'll do good songs later.
Well, these are good songs.
Wait.
Who does Cotton Eye Joe?
Rednecks?
No way.
No way that's the name of the group.
Rednecks.
With an X.
If I am being for Cotton Eye Joe, I've been married a long time ago.
Where did you come from?
Where did you go?
Cotton Eye Joe.
If I am being for Cotton Eye Joe, I've been married a long time ago.
Where did you come from?
Where did you go?
Cotton Eye Joe.
If I am being for Cotton Eye Joe.
If
I am being for Cotton Eye Joe.
There's more to this song?
I've been married a long time ago.
This is the only part of the song I know.
Where did you come from?
Cotton Eye Joe.
If I am being for Cotton Eye Joe, I
am.
Where did you come from?
Where did you go?
Cotton Eye Joe.
I was Cotton Eye Joe.
Maybe I should focus on myself.
Maybe I have a bad personality.
Hey!
Even I've been for Cotton Eye Joe, I've been married a long time ago.
Bobbi girl!
This one is for you M.O.D.
Thanks for the gift that you guys!
Thank-You!
Wait!
Here we go.
Hi Bobbi.
Hi Ken.
You wanna go for a ride?
Sure Ken.
Jump in.
I'm a Barbie girl, in a Barbie world.
Life in plastic, it's fantastic.
You can brush my hair, undress me everywhere.
Imagination, life is your creation.
Come on Barbie, let's go party!
I'm a Barbie girl, in a Barbie world.
Life in plastic, it's fantastic.
You can brush my hair, undress me everywhere.
Imagination, life is your creation.
I'm a blonde bimbo girl, in a fantasy world.
Dress me up, make it tight, I'm your dolly.
You're my doll, rock and roll, feel the glamour and bing.
Kiss me here, touch me there, hanky panky.
You can touch, you can play, if you say, I'm always yours.
I'm a Barbie girl, in a Barbie world.
Life in plastic, it's fantastic.
You can brush my hair, undress me everywhere.
Imagination, life is your creation.
It's fantastic.
You can brush my hair, undress me everywhere.
Imagination, life is your creation.
Come on Barbie, let's go potty.
Ah, ah, ah, yeah.
Ooh, ooh.
Come on Barbie, let's go potty.
Ah, ah, ah, yeah.
Ooh, ooh.
Make me walk, make me talk, do whatever you please.
I can act like a star, I can beg on my knees.
Come jump in, bimbo friend, let us do it again.
Hit the town, fool around, let's go potty.
You can touch, you can play, if you say it's yours.
You can touch, you can play, if you say I'm always yours.
Come on Barbie, let's go potty.
Ah, ah, ah, yeah.
Ooh, ooh.
Come on Barbie, let's go potty.
Ah, ah, ah, yeah.
Ooh, ooh.
In
plastic, it's fantastic.
You can brush my hair, undress me everywhere.
Imagination, life is your creation.
I'm a Barbie girl, in a Barbie world.
Life in plastic, it's fantastic.
You can brush my hair, undress me everywhere.
Imagination, life is your creation.
Come on Barbie, let's go potty.
Ah, ah, ah, yeah.
Ooh, ooh.
Come on Barbie, let's go potty.
Ah, ah, ah, yeah.
Ooh, ooh.
Oh, I'm having so much fun, Ken.
Come on Barbie, let's go potty.
Well, Barbie, we're just getting started.
Oh, I love you, Ken.
Sorry to any Kens in the chat.
That song makes me want to act.
That song makes me want to be Barbie.
Yay!
Superstar Misa.
She's my wife.
Wait, did it have that?
Oh my God, thank you for the Aka-Soufa.
Love Fool by the Thug.
The cardigans.
Love it, you're singing too.
Love fool.
Let me look it up.
Also, whoever requested anything earlier, I couldn't find it.
I'm sorry.
She's my wife.
She is my wife.
This is the acapella version.
No boa duvet.
I'm saving some of the slower songs for later.
Later.
Right now it's kind of like all the funky fun songs.
And then we'll do like the slower like...
So if you have a slower song... I have it written down.
I'm gonna... dancing queen!
Yeah.
Let me look up love fool real quick.
See if I know it or not.
Love fool.
No, I don't even see it on here.
Oh, wait.
Let me see if I can find a karaoke on YouTube.
I don't even know if she's my wife would have a karaoke.
If you search up Dazuhiro on your art tag, there's a microphone for your first anniversary.
Really?
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I'll use it.
I'll use it next time.
Let me write it down though.
Dazuhiro.
Thanks Dazuhiro!
I like how you're like, if you search up Dazuhiro as if I don't know your name.
Mike.
On Twitter.
I know you.
Hercules tsundere song.
Okay.
You know me.
I'll always do.
I'll always do some nice... some Disney.
7192!
Thank you so much for the ride!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much!
Hope you had a fun stream.
Dreams by Fleetwood Mac.
Don't stop me now!
Oh my gosh.
I can't sing that song.
Elizabeth sang that song way too well.
She sang that song like she was the queen!
I can't stop listening to her singing that.
It's so good!
Oh my gosh.
She...
I can listen.
I love how she had like her karaoke like...
It was going on for like 10 hours today.
It was crazy.
Like all her unarchived stuff.
I was watching it earlier.
What was I searching?
Oh, Love Fool.
By Cardigans.
Karaoke?
Let me see.
Hold on.
Let me see if I know this first.
Mmm-mmm.
Oh!
I fear we're facing a problem.
You love me.
No longer I know it.
Maybe there is nothing that I can do to make you do all I can.
Mama tells me I shouldn't bother that I ought just to stay.
I don't know this song very well.
So I cry and I pray and I beg.
Love me, love me.
Say that you love me.
Fool me, fool me.
Go on and fool me.
Love me, love me.
Pretend that you love me.
Leave me, leave me.
Just say that you need me.
So I cry and I beg for you to love me, love me.
Say that you love me.
Leave me, leave me.
Just say that you need me.
I can't care about anything but you.
I have desperately pondered.
Spent my nights awake and I wonder what I could have done in another way to make you stay.
Reason will not lead to solution.
I will end up lost in confusion.
I don't care...
Oh my gosh, I've been forgetting to update the setlist for so long.
I'm so sorry.
Haha.
Go.
So I cry and I pray and I beg.
Love me, love me.
Say that you love me.
Fool me, fool me.
Go on and fool me.
Love me, love me.
Pretend that you love me.
Leave me, leave me.
Just say that you need me.
So I cry and I beg for you to love me, love me.
Say that you love me.
Leave me, leave me.
Just say that you need me.
I can't care about anything but you.
Anything but you.
Love me, love me.
Say that you love me.
Fool me, fool me.
Go on and fool me.
Love me, love me.
I know that you need me.
I can't care about anything but you.
Sorry, Oimo.
I think I butchered your song.
Okay, I will remember to update the setlist now.
Or not setlist, but the now playing.
I think on a vertical format, having a setlist is hard.
Oh, sorry, my bad.
Go to bed when you need to.
Asian Kung Fu Generation rewrite.
I love that song.
I'm parasocial.
Dreams, dreams from nights.
I don't know that one.
I believe in a thing called love by the darkness.
Wait, do I know that one?
Oh my gosh.
You guys suggest so many songs.
I'm sorry if I can't get to everything.
Tattoo!
Okay.
I think I can sing Tattoo.
They're not gonna get us.
Wait, I don't know if I remember this song.
I'll try it.
Get us.
They're not gonna get us.
Not gonna get us.
Starting from here.
Let's make a promise.
You and me.
Let's just be honest.
We're gonna run.
Nothing can stop us.
Even the night that falls all around us.
Soon there will be laughter and voices.
Beyond the clouds.
Over the mountains.
I don't know if I'm getting the keys right at all.
That are empty.
Lights from the airfield.
Shining above you.
Nothing can stop us.
No, no, I love you.
They're not gonna get us.
Nothing can stop us.
No, no, I love you.
They're not gonna get us.
Get
us!
Uh oh!
I think I'm getting the rides wrong.
Not gonna haunt us!
We
rush ahead.
The crossroads are empty.
Our spirits rise.
They're not gonna get us.
Always forever.
Just you and me.
All else is nothing.
Not going back.
Not going back there.
They don't understand.
They don't understand us.
Not gonna get us.
Nothing can stop us.
No, no, I love you.
They're not gonna get us.
Nothing can stop us.
No, no, I love you.
They're not gonna get us.
Not gonna get us.
Wow, I haven't heard that song in probably like 10 years.
That's crazy.
I don't know if I got the keys or the verses right at all.
Why does the background vocals sound like Spongebob singing?
Someone suggested this earlier.
I'll do my best with it, but...
Don't compare me to a certain...
You know... singer.
I'm not a singer.
I'll take lessons.
I'll take lessons someday.
I'm inside out.
I'm floating around in ecstasy.
So don't stop me now.
Don't stop me cause I'm having a good time.
I'm shooting a star leaping through the sky.
Like a tiger, defying the laws of gravity.
I'm racing a car passing by.
It's a good time.
Gotta go, go, go.
There's no stopping me.
I'm burning through the sky.
200 degrees, that's why I call me Mr. Fahrenheit.
I'm traveling at the speed of light.
I wanna make a supersonic man out of you.
Don't stop me now.
I'm having such a good time.
I'm having a ball.
Don't stop me now.
If you don't wanna have a good time.
Wait, wait, if you don't wanna have a good time.
Don't stop me now.
Cause I'm having a good time.
Yes, I'm having a good time.
Don't wanna stop at all.
I'm a rocket ship.
I'm with my boys.
On a collision course.
I'm a satellite.
I'm out of control.
I'm a sex machine.
Ready to reload.
Like an atom bomb.
Bout to oh, oh, oh, oh.
I'll explode.
I'm burning through the sky.
Oh yeah.
200 degrees.
It's all my cousin.
I wanna make a supersonic woman out of you.
Oh, why did I even attempt this song?
Don't stop me.
No, stop this song.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
Don't stop me.
Good times.
I don't even know how to stop.
No
stopping.
Don't stop me.
Don't stop
me.
Don't stop me.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
200 degrees.
That's why they call me Mr. Fahrenheit.
I'm travelling at the speed of light.
I wanna make a supersonic man out of you.
Don't stop me now.
I'm having such a good time.
I'm having a ball.
Don't stop me now.
I'm gonna have a good time.
Just give me a call.
Don't stop me now.
Let's have a good time.
Don't stop me.
Yes, I'm having a goo...
Tararino.
Oh, that's the rest?
Wait, I thought it went to the rest.
Oh my god.
Sorry, I've totally butchered that.
It's fine.
The coffee is starting to weigh down actually.
That's why I'm like trying to eat because I was like, oh gosh, the caffeine is like passing through me and now I need food because I'm starting to shake.
Mamma mia time.
Okay.
You're a pretty good singer.
I'm not, but thank you.
I'm not, but thanks.
I appreciate it.
Mamma mia.
What's a song from Mamma Mia?
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the 50 gift.
And I think I, oh sorry.
I think I saw Paco right in me.
I think it was you, Paco.
Thank you.
If you're still here.
Hello, I'm in Phantom.
Anybody who doesn't know.
Let's do Abba.
Abba Abba.
It'll be in my heart.
Oh my god.
None.
It's like the one Disney song.
I don't know.
Holy moly.
That scared me.
You can dance.
You can jive.
Have you
seen that girl?
Watch that scene.
Dig in the dancing queen.
Friday night and the lights are low.
Looking out for a place to go.
Where they play the right music.
Getting in swing.
You gotta look for a king.
Anybody could be that guy.
The night is young and the music solved.
Hi, with a bit of rock music, everything is fine.
You're in the mood for a dance.
And when you get the chance, you are the dancing queen.
Young and sweet, forever 19.
Dancing queen, feel the beat from the tambourine, oh yeah.
You can dance, you can jive, and
we'll see that girl, watch that scene, dig in the dancing queen.
Watch
that stream.
You're a teaser, you turn him on.
Leave him burning and then you're gone.
You're in the mood for a dance.
And when you get the chance, you are the dancing queen.
Young and sweet, forever 19.
Dancing queen, feel the beat from the tambourine, oh yeah.
You can dance, you can jive, and
we'll see that girl, watch that scene, dig in the freaky queen.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
That was the dancing queen.
Young and sweet.
Hopefully that suffices for Mamma Mia.
Because I don't know, actually I only know, Mamma Mia, here I go again.
A bunch of us are at Anime Fest learning what to get to the stream.
Is Kenjo teaching you guys?
Nice.
Thanks for watching, even at Anime Fest.
Take on me!
Sometimes I only recommend songs that I know, and it's hard to tell which songs you're familiar with.
No, it's okay!
Always feel free, like you can suggest a song.
Just because I don't know it, doesn't mean I won't be able to sing it in the future.
Sung Bohemian Rhapsody?
I haven't.
Should I sing it?
I'll do it after this one.
Take on me.
Bohemian Rhapsody.
Gosh, I need to warm up my voice.
I mean, I have, like, been singing, but it's like...
And I never do, like, vocal warm-ups.
I just kind of was like, I'm just gonna go in for this, baby.
We're talking away.
I don't know what I'm to say.
I'll say it anyway.
Today's another day to find you.
Shying away.
I'll be coming for you, love, okay.
Take on me.
Take me on.
So
needless to say.
I'm at odds and ends.
But I'll be stumbling away.
Slowly learning that life is okay.
Say after me.
It's either too low or too high.
It's no better to be safe than sorry.
Take on me.
How do I do this part?
Take me on.
Take on me.
Help me God.
In a day or two.
My
warm -ups.
For
me.
I was practicing the higher one.
They were boring.
I don't even know the notes.
This is Piquan approaching.
All the things that you say.
Is it life or just to play my worries away?
You're all the things I've got to remember.
You shying away.
I'll be coming for you anyway.
Take on me.
Take me.
Take me on.
I'll be gone.
In a day or.
Take me on.
I'll be gone.
In a day.
Take me on.
Take on me.
Where's the two?
Take me on.
Take on me.
Ha!
That part confused the hell out of me.
Oh, that was take on me.
My god.
You guys, why do I even sing?
Why do I even sing?
Why are you guys even listening to me?
Got another suggestion.
Scatman?
Oh my gosh, wait!
I did Scatman earlier!
I did, I did, I did, I did Scatman.
I did it, I did it, I did it, I did it, I did it.
Okay, I'm gonna do a song.
Maybe that actually... Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Serious time.
This song goes through my entire rage.
Kenji's freaking out.
What's the song in Yota G2?
Heavens divide.
Living la vida loca?
Okay.
How do you know that song?
My god, Ricky Martin.
I used to have such a crush on that guy.
So did my grandma.
I think I...
Oh, it's a trick!
That's right!
She's into superstitions.
Black cats and voodoo dolls.
I feel a premonition.
That girl's gonna make me fall.
She's into sensations.
New kicks in the candlelight.
She's got a new addiction.
For every day and night.
She'll make you take your clothes off.
And go dancing in the rain.
She'll make you live her crazy life.
But she'll take away your pain.
Like a bullet to your brain.
Come on!
Upside, inside, out.
Living la vida loca.
She'll push and pull you down.
Her lips are devil rings.
And her skin is the color of mocha.
She will wear you out.
Living la vida loca.
She's living la vida loca.
Woke up in New York City.
In a funky cheap hotel.
She took my heart.
She took my money.
She must have slipped me a sleeping pill.
What?
She never drinks the water.
Makes you order French champagne.
Once you've had a taste of her.
You'll never be the same.
Yeah, she'll make you go insane.
Come on!
Upside, inside, out.
She's living la vida loca.
She'll push and pull you down.
Living la vida loca.
Her lips are devil rings.
And her skin is the color of mocha.
She will wear you out.
Living la vida loca.
She's living la vida loca.
She'll
make you take your clothes off.
And go dancing in the rain.
She'll make you live her crazy life.
But she'll take away your pain.
Like a bullet to your brain.
Come on!
Upside, inside, out.
Vida loca.
She'll push and pull you down.
Living la vida loca.
Her lips are devil red.
And her skin's the color of mocha.
She will wear you out.
Living la vida loca.
Upside, inside, out.
She's living la vida loca.
What is this part?
Come on!
I never knew what the lyrics of that song were.
Oh my god.
He literally was just like, she made me... or she drugged me in the night and she took my money.
She gave me a sleeping pill and she took my money.
I'll never financially recover.
Oh my god.
I'm kinda into it.
You're freaky.
Shadowcross, thank you for the tiny gift then.
Popipo.
You're a stupid.
Tiny princess, thank you.
Bro got scammed.
Okay,
it might be time to start chilling out.
It's starting to get late in the night.
Bohemian Rhapsody.
I can do Bohemian Rhapsody.
What is the edit?
Holden... what's that?
Is that the... Holden out for... wait.
Holden out for a hero.
I don't know that.
Wait.
I know that one but I don't know that one.
Is this the real life?
Is this just fantasy?
Caught in a landslide.
No escape from reality.
Open your eyes.
Look up to the skies and see.
I'm just a poor ghost.
I need no sympathy.
Cause I'm easy come, easy go.
Little high, little low.
Any way the wind blows.
Doesn't really matter to me.
To me.
Mama.
Just killed a man.
Put a gun against his head.
Pulled my trigger.
Now he's dead.
Mama.
Life had just begun.
But now I've gone and thrown it all away.
Mama.
Didn't mean to make you cry.
If I'm not back again this time tomorrow.
Carry on.
As if nothing really matters.
Too late.
My time has come.
Sent shivers down my spine.
Body's aching all the time.
Goodbye everybody.
I've got to go.
Gotta leave you all behind.
And face the truth.
Mama.
I don't wanna die.
I sometimes wish I'd never been born at all.
Today.
Oh seven.
I see a little silhetto of man.
Scaramouche, Scaramouche will you do the fantastico.
Thunderbolts of lightning very, very frightening me.
Galileo.
Galileo, Galileo, Galileo Figaro magnificao.
I'm just a poor ghost, nobody loves me.
He's just a poor boy from a poor family.
Spare him his life from this monstrosity.
Easy come, easy go, will you let me go?
Bismillah!
No!
We will not let you go!
Let him go!
Bismillah!
We will not let you go!
Never let you go!
Never let me go!
No!
Mamma mia!
Let me go!
Me as a pup, as a devil put aside for me!
For me!
Yeah!
So
you think you can stone me and spit in my eye?
So you think you can love me and leave me?
To die?
Oh baby!
Can't do this to me baby!
Just gotta get out!
Just gotta get right outta here!
Nothing really matters.
Anyone can see.
Nothing really matters to me.
Except Metal Gear.
Anyway the wind blows.
Bohemian Rhapsody.
Maybe that was a good one to end in the craziness, right?
I don't know.
I might go back to crazy.
Can we get Mamma Mia?
I don't know!
Mamma Mia!
I'm sorry!
That's why I sang Dancing Queen.
That's why I sang Viva La Vida.
Oh yeah, that's a good one.
I might have to turn it up though.
Let me up the pitch.
Elton John.
I'll put...
Let me do Elton John.
Actually, I wonder if I can just sing this one.
Okay.
Let's see if I can do this one.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I think it's too high.
Hold on.
Let me start over.
I'm gonna...
Do this.
Let me try that.
Let me try one more time.
Okay.
Okay,
I'm gonna do it one more time.
Okay.
I know it.
I know it now.
Okay.
Are you guys sick of this opening yet?
Okay, there we go.
I used to rule the world.
Seas would rise when I gave the word.
Now in the morning I sleep alone.
Sweep the streets I used to own.
Again!
I'm back!
Haha!
I used to roll the dice.
Feel the fear in my enemy's eyes.
Listen as the crowd would sing.
Now the old king is dead.
Long live the king.
One minute I held the key.
Next the walls were closed on me.
And I discovered that my castles stand upon pillars of salt, pillars of sand.
I hear Jerusalem bells are ringing.
Roman cavalry choirs are singing.
Be my mirror, my sword, my shield.
My missionaries in a foreign field.
For some reason I can't explain.
Once you go there was never, never an honest word.
That was when I ruled the world.
What's the meme lyrics?
It was the wicked and wild wind Blew the doors to let me in Shattered windows and the sound of drums People could not believe what I'd become Revolutionaries wait For my head on a silver plate Just a puppet on a lonely string Oh, who would ever want to be king?
I hear Jerusalem bells are ringing Roman cavalry choirs are singing Be my mirror, my sword, my shield My missionaries in the foreign field For some reason I can't explain I know Saint Peter won't call my name Never an honest word But that was when I Ruled the world
Saint Mito!
Video
of the king reminiscing That's destroyed Minecraft I hear Jerusalem bells are ringing Roman cavalry choirs are singing Be my mirror, my sword, my shield My missionaries in the foreign field For some reason I can't explain I know Saint Peter won't call my name Never an honest word But that was when I ruled the world What's the lyrics?
What's the Minecraft lyrics?
Minecraft...
Chunks would load when I gave the word Hide the mobs I used to slay No block choirs
It was the creepers and the skeletons Blew down the doors and boxed us in What is this?
This is so stupid I gaze off at the boundless skyline No block choirs playing in the sunshine This is awful Oh my god, it's art Do one verse...
Okay, okay, I'll do it, I'll do it Hold on Minecraft...
Wait, uh, uh, oh, oh Oh wait, no, no, no It's gonna sound really funky Wait for a second Wait
Oh wait, I lost the lyrics Where did they go?
Oh I love my baby I boobie bop Oh my god Oh hold on, hold on I exited out of the lyrics I'm an idiot Wait, oh
Oh, okay, hold on Oh, okay, hold on
Okay, I love BGM while I search for stuff
I used to rule the world Chunks would load when I gave the word Now every night I go stow away Hide from the mobs I used to slay
Yeah, this is so stupid
They once were terrified Every time I looked into their eyes Villagers would cheer my way For a hero I was That's what they'd say One minute we had it all Next our world began to fall Away from it that it once become They all cried for my help But I stood there numb I'd gaze off into the boundless skyline No block choirs playing in the sunshine Turn around,
pick up my sword and wield The blade that once feared evil Bombs to yield And hope one day that this chaos and Destruction turns for the better Never a bow in hand That was when I ruled the land
It was the creepers and skeletons Blew down doors and boxed us in Arrows whizzing by like streaks of light I tried all that I could to stay and fight As the undead roamed the street Family's broken at my feet Life itself's just suspended by a thread Oh,
why was it that I wasn't dead?
I gaze off into the boundless skyline No block wires playing in the sunshine Turn around, pick up my sword and wield The blade that once forced evil mobs to yield If this battle should leave me slain I know Herobrine will call my name Better to take a stand That was when I ruled the land I
gaze off
into the boundless skyline No block wires playing in the sunshine
My crooked glasses just... just bring it all together now, doesn't it?
Oh, there we go.
Good job, everybody.
Oh, okay, I'm starting to get tired, I'm starting to get tired.
Starting to get tired, I'm starting to get tired.
Let's see what else can... oh no, okay.
Oops.
Now I still have a little bit in me, don't worry.
And you don't seem to understand A shame you seemed an honest man And all the fears you hold so dear Will turn to whisper in your ear And you know what they say might hurt you And you know that it means so much
I am falling, I am fading, I have lost it all, and you don't seem the lying kind, a shame that I can read your mind.
And all the things I read, that I read there, candlelit smile that we both share, and you know I don't mean to hurt you, but you know that it means so much, and you don't even feel a thing.
I am falling, I am fading, I am drowning.
Help me to breathe, I am hurting, I have lost it all, I am losing, help me to breathe.
Present day, present time, ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Help
me to breathe, I am hurting, I am hurting, I am losing, help me to breathe.
I have lost it all, I am losing, help me to breathe.
Help me to
breathe, I am hurting, I have lost it all, I am losing, help me to breathe.
I have lost it all, I am hurting, I am losing, help me to breathe.
I have lost it all, I am losing, help me to breathe.
I have lost
it all, I am losing, help me to breathe.
I have lost it all, I am losing, help me to breathe.
I'm not good at singing karaoke in this style, but you know.
Hold on, I'm looking it up.
Oh, I remember, I remember.
I remember, I remember.
Karaoke.
Let me check if this is good.
This song.
I have to use a YouTube one.
It's uploaded 16 years ago.
You know what, who cares if the quality is bad.
This was supposed to be a bad quality stream anyway, right?
You're not here to hear me sing well.
Oh, I forgot to look up lyrics.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm not gonna lie, I started to disassociate during the song.
I started to be like...
I felt like an out of body experience.
I was like, am I...
Am I singing this right now?
Actually, it's so funny because I know that song is from Full Metal Panic.
But...
I actually know that song so well.
I only watched a few episodes of Full Metal Panic because...
When I was a kid, I owned some of the DVDs.
Right?
Thank you for the 20 gift!
Thank you!
Panda!
Thank you for the 20 gift!
Thank you!
And...
But actually, I know the song so well.
Because there was a Petite Princesse Uchiha AMV to it.
That was made so well.
And I fell so much in love with the song.
That I always watched the music.
The AMV.
And also...
Listen to the song.
Does anybody remember Petite Princesse Uchiha?
Anyway, I have no idea.
I don't actually remember the songs from that.
I don't remember.
Actually, there was an AMV.
I watched that too.
That was...
Oh my gosh.
Let's see.
Somebody requested Hercules.
There was something else I just saw.
And I was like...
Oh, this would be good.
I don't remember.
Sorry.
Somewhere over the rainbow.
You know what?
Oh!
I remember.
I wonder...
Sorry, this is a...
This is a loud song.
And then I'll go back to the quiet songs.
Kimi ga nozomu eien.
Sorry!
But...
Ano anime no kyoku wo oboite nai.
Kimi ga nozomu eien no kyoku ga oboite nai.
Opening to ending no kyoku.
Creep by Radiohead.
Oh!
I might be able to...
Oh, I don't know.
Can I sing that song?
Can I try that one next time?
I actually don't remember it at all.
Well, I do remember it.
But I wanna do it justice.
I like that song.
Okay, this one is like from my childhood.
I used to listen to this song all the time.
All the time.
I don't even think I'll be able to sing it very well.
But I just kinda wanna sing it.
I just kinda wanna sing it.
Broken this fragile thing now.
And I can't, I can't pick up the pieces.
And I've thrown my words all around.
But I can't, I can't give you a reason.
I feel so broken up.
And I give up.
I just want to tell you so you know.
Here I go.
Scream my lungs out and try to get to you.
You are my only one.
I let go.
But there's no one who gets me like you do.
You are my only, my only one.
Oh my gosh, I used to scream this as a kid.
Made my mistakes let you down.
And I can't, I can't hold on for too long.
Ran my whole life in the ground.
And I can't, I can't get up when you're gone.
Somethings breaking up.
I feel like giving up.
I won't walk out until you know.
Here I go.
Scream my lungs out and try to get to you.
You are my only one.
I let go.
There's just no one who gets me like you do.
You are my only one.
I
clearly don't remember this song well enough.
I could have sworn there was a quiet part.
It's a song.
Am I
crazy?
Am I crazy?
I could have sworn there was a part where he was like, here I go.
Maybe they cut the solo out.
Really?
That's what messed me up so much.
Anyway, that was yellow card, only one.
Okay, let's sing some Disney.
Disney, Disney, Disney, Disney, Disney, Disney.
What Disney song should I sing?
Disney, Disney.
Oh my gosh, it's easy!
Thank you for the $50 gift and thank you!
Thank you, thank you so much!
When she loved me... Oh, I sang that in a membership one, I think.
Oh yeah, it's... Okay.
It's quiet, I think.
Quiet hours, everybody.
Quiet hours.
It's late.
It's time for quiet songs.
Wait, is this the right one?
No.
I think it's this one.
Sorry, my bad.
My bad.
We got some dramatic piano for no reason.
When somebody loved me, everything was beautiful.
Every hour spent together lives within my heart.
And when she was sad, I was there to dry her tears.
And when she was happy, so was I.
When she loved me... Through the summer and the fall, we had each other, that was all.
Just she and I together, like it was meant to be.
And when she was lonely, I was there to comfort her.
And I knew that she loved me.
So the years went by, I stayed the same.
But she began to drift away.
I was left alone.
Still I waited for the day, when she'd say I will always love you.
Lonely and forgotten, never thought she'd look my way.
And she smiled at me and held me, just like she used to do.
Like she loved me, when she loved me.
When somebody loved me, everything was beautiful.
Every hour we spent together lives within my heart.
When she loved me...
Oh, sorry, I forgot to change it.
Yay.
I have another one I want to sing, I hope it's okay.
I haven't sung this one in a really long time, so I hope I remember how to sing it.
Good.
So Jamie, thank you.
Look at me.
I'm as helpless as a kitten up a tree.
And I feel like I'm clinging to a cloud.
I can't understand.
I get misty.
Just holding your hand.
My
way.
And a thousand violins begin to play.
Or it might be the sound of your hello.
That music I hear.
I get minty.
The moment you're near.
Can't you see that you're leading me on?
And it's just what I want you to do.
Don't you notice?
How hopelessly I'm lost.
That's why I'm following you on
my own.
Would I wander through this wonderland alone?
Never knowing my right foot from my left.
My hand from my glove.
I'm too minty.
And too much in love.
Too misty.
And too...
In love.
Yay.
That was misty.
But you could say minty.
Yay.
Thanks for the claps.
Clap, clap, clap, clap.
Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap.
Thank you.
Skyfall.
Oh gosh.
I don't know if I could sing it tonight.
Micmac.
Thanks for the five gifted.
Making that borderline.
Maybe another night.
Fine, fine line from Avenue Q.
Have I ever sung this on stream before?
Hey I'm dragon.
Thanks for the ten gifted.
I used to audition with this song.
Um...
I used to audition for musicals with this song.
Good evening, Minto.
Good evening.
There's a fine fine line Between a lover and a friend There's a fine fine line Between reality and pretend And you never know till you reach the top
No, I never got in.
There's a fine, fine line between a fairy tale and a lie.
And there's a fine, fine line between your wonderful and goodbye.
I guess if someone doesn't love you back, it isn't such a crime.
But there's a fine, fine line between love and a waste of your time.
And I don't have the time to waste on you anymore.
I don't think that you even know what you're looking for.
For my own sanity, I've got to close the door and walk away.
Oh.
There's a fine, fine line between together and you.
And there's a fine, fine line between what you wanted and what you got.
You gotta go after the things you want while you're still in your prime.
There's a fine, fine line between love and a waste of your time.
I was about to say something really mean.
Oh, man.
Yeah, I never... I would... Maybe I should have changed what song I auditioned with because I never got into anything using that song, so... Oh, well.
I just really liked it, though.
Say it!
Oh, no, I don't... She hates us?
No, no.
Not about you.
It's... It's about where I used to work.
Oh, man.
Anyway.
Let's see.
I don't think I did any Disney, did I?
No.
Let's see.
Someone... Oh, Hercules.
That's right.
What's that song?
Gwant?
Just a box.
If there's a prize for rotten judgment, I guess I already won that.
No man is worth the aggravation.
That's ancient history.
Been there, done that.
Who do you think you're kidding?
He's the earth and heaven to you.
Try to keep it hidden.
Honey, we can see right through you.
Girl, you can't conceal it.
We know how you feel and who you're thinking of.
Oh, no chance, no way, I won't say no, no.
You swoon, you sigh, why deny it?
Oh, it's too cliche.
I won't say I won't in love.
Sorry.
You swoon, you sigh, why deny it?
Oh, it's too cliche.
I won't say I won't in love.
Sorry.
You swoon, you sigh, why deny it?
Oh, it's too cliche.
I won't say I won't in love.
Sorry.
Sometimes it just isn't fair, to miss that cause I really, really believe it.
I thought my heart had learned its lesson.
It feels so good when you start out.
Oh.
My head is screaming, get a grip, girl!
Unless you're dying to cry your heart out.
Oh, oh anyway...
Oh no!
Sorry, my throat is so bad today.
Oh, no chance, no way, I won't say it, no, no.
I blame crazy frog.
This scene won't play, I won't say I'm in love.
Your way, oh god, I won't say it.
Get out my case, I won't say it.
Need more water.
At
least I'm loud.
I won't say I'm in love.
I
like hearing your throat sounds.
What the hell?
I might unarchive this since I sound so bad tonight.
Sorry, I thought I'd be fine.
I'm so out of water though.
It's okay, I'm having fun.
What's another Disney song I like?
Golden Hour?
Sound great, can it, nerd?
Takes one to know one.
Geez.
Wait.
Beauty and the Beast.
Which version do I want to sing?
Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, no, no, no.
Not this one.
Wait, do I have to turn this one up?
Do I have to...
I don't remember if I have to up this one or not.
I'll see you in a second.
Sally Song!
Oh, I can try.
It goes really high though.
Hold on.
This is a test.
I have to see if I need to pitch it up or not.
I was the one who had it all.
I was the master of my fate.
I never needed anybody in my life.
I learned the truth too late.
I'll never shake away the pain.
I close my eyes but she's still there.
I let her steal into my melancholy heart.
It's more than I can bear.
Now I know she'll never leave me, even as she runs away.
She will still torment me, calm me, hurt me, move me, come what may.
Wasting in my lonely tower, waiting by an open door.
I'll fool myself, she'll walk right in.
And be with me forevermore.
I rage against the trials of love.
I curse the fading of the light.
Though she's already flown so far beyond my reach.
She's never out of my reach.
Now I know she'll never leave me, even as she fades from view.
She will still inspire me, be a part of everything I do.
Wasting in my lonely tower, waiting by an open door.
I'll fool myself, she'll walk right in.
And as the long, long nights begin.
I'll think of all that might have been.
Waiting here forevermore.
Oh, I couldn't hold it.
For Papa, I will stay.
But I don't deserve to lose my freedom in this way.
You monster.
If you think that what you've done is right, well then, you're a fool.
Think again.
I always wanted to be Belle on Broadway.
It's always my dream role.
My dreamest, dreamest role.
Is this home?
Is this where I should learn to be happy?
Never dreamed that a home could be dark and blue.
And cold.
I was told.
Every day in my childhood, even when we grow old.
Home will be where the heart is.
Never were words so true.
My heart's far, far away.
Home is too.
Is this home?
Is this what I must learn to believe in?
Try to find something good in this tragic place.
Just in case.
I should stay here forever.
Held in this empty space.
Hold up.
But that won't do.
It won't be easy.
I know the reason why.
My heart's far, far away.
Home's a lie.
What I'd give to return to the life that I knew lately.
But I know that I can't solve my problems.
Going back.
Is this home?
Am I here for a day or forever?
Shot away.
From the world until who knows when.
As my life has been altered.
Once it can change again.
Build higher walls around me.
Change every lock and key.
Nothing lasts.
Nothing holds.
All of me.
My heart's far, far away.
Home...
It's only from the musical.
Beauty and the Beast.
Oh, sorry.
You can't read it.
Beauty and...
Beauty and the Beast.
Thank you.
Someone requested.
Almost there.
Oh, hold on.
I know Gold... People have been screaming about Golden Hour.
Okay.
I'll get it.
I'll do it.
Newsies?
I'm sorry.
I actually don't know Newsies.
It was just two lovers sitting in the car.
Listening to Blonde.
Falling for each other.
Pink and orange skies.
Feeling super child.
There's no Donald Glover.
Miss Glover, my mother.
Like you were yet tonight.
Got no alibi.
All I was all alone.
With the love of my life.
She's got glitter for skin.
My radiant beam in the night.
I don't need no light.
To see you shine.
It's your Golden Hour.
You slowed down time.
In your Golden Hour.
We were just two lovers.
Feet up on the dash.
Driving over fast.
Burning through the summer.
Radio on blast.
Make the moment last.
She got solar power.
Minutes feel like hours.
She knew she was the baddest.
Can you even imagine?
Falling like I did.
For the love of my life.
She's got glow on her face.
A glorious look in her eyes.
My angel of light.
I was all alone.
With the love of my life.
She's got glitter for skin.
My radiant beam in the night.
She's got the light of her life.
I don't need no light.
To see you shine.
It's your golden hour.
You slow down time.
In your golden hour.
Oh, so
is that girl.
Oh, so is that girl.
I'm the longest outro ever.
Auto-caffeine?
I think so.
Mama, I don't have time for dancing.
That's just gonna have to wait a while.
Ain't got time for messing around.
And it's not my style.
This whole town can slow you down.
People taking the easy way.
But I know exactly where I'm going.
Getting closer and closer every day.
And I'm almost there.
I'm almost there.
People down here think I'm crazy.
But I don't care.
Trials and tribulations.
I've had my share.
There ain't nothing gonna stop me now.
Cause I'm almost there.
I remember daddy told me.
Fairy tales can come true.
You gotta make them happen.
It all depends on you.
So I work real hard each and every day.
Now things for sure are going my way.
Just doing what I do.
Look out boys, I'm coming through.
And I'm almost there.
I'm almost there.
People gonna come here from everywhere.
And I'm almost there.
I'm almost
there.
There's been trials and tribulations.
You know I've had my share.
But I've climbed the mountain.
I've crossed the river.
And I'm almost there.
I'm almost there.
Almost there.
You're there?
I don't think so.
But that's okay.
I wonder if this song is on here.
I don't see it.
Oh well.
Shadow cross.
Six of the five gifted.
I never know when to stop.
I always just want to keep going.
Hmm.
Trying to think.
Oh someone requested this.
And I do kind of want to sing it.
It'll help us go to sleep.
Actually it's a song that my mom used to sing to me to sleep.
Every night.
So.
I might cry.
It's probably not a song you hear very much in Vtuber karaoke.
But that's okay.
This should be a song that you guys listen to if you read the song.
But honestly, It's okay.
Every time I lie down, especially if I'm not able to sleep.
I看 the radio in my head or something like that.
geme
I was right.
I was artwork -able.
There's a land that I've heard of once in a lullaby Somewhere over the rainbow, the skies are blue And the dreams that you dare to dream Really do come true Someday I'll wish upon a star And wake up where the clouds are far behind me Where troubles melt like lemon drops Away above the chimney tops That's where you'll find me,
somewhere over the rainbow, bluebirds fly, birds fly over the rainbow.
Why, oh why, can't... I
don't know this version at all.
It says it's the Judy Garland version, but...
If happy little bluebirds fly beyond the rainbow, why, oh why...
Yay!
Oh, I'm not gonna lie, I was tearing up.
I was tearing up.
Any other lullaby songs?
What's another lullaby song?
What's another really quiet, soft song?
What's a song to sleep to?
Sad song when you think about it.
When you think about her, Judy Garland?
I know, right?
Gosh, so sad.
Where's her whole thing?
Letter?
Break stuff, yeah.
Have a good sleep, Minto.
Thank you.
I'll do one more.
Moon River, oh my gosh, I did that song in a recital once.
I'm truly gobsmacked.
What's that mean?
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
That's so sad.
Okay.
You know what?
End on a Metal Gear song.
Oh, technically.
Actually, is there a slow version or is it only the fast version?
I think there's only the fast version, right?
Let me see.
I think it's only the fast version.
Oh.
Oh, it's the slow version.
Okay, good.
Oh my god, it's buzzing in my right ear.
Wait, I think it picks up, actually.
07, 07.
I think it's gonna get louder in a second.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's- oh, oh, that's it.
Sorry, I wasn't looking.
Oh, is it- I wonder if there's a- I wonder if there's a slow version.
Like MGS4 version.
Hold on, I'm checking.
Sorry.
Sorry, I'm checking.
Hold on, let me see if this works.
It'll actually be a real... a real bedtime song then, maybe.
The slow version is from 4.
Yeah, this one, the faster one is... I think it's the original one is the fastest one, but it's also...
It's also...
It's also... what's the word?
Oh my gosh.
It's also... the one in the end of 4 is I think what I was going to say.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sorry,
I'm checking.
I want to make sure I get the ad-libs right, but you know what?
It's fine, I guess.
Okay.
That should be it.
MGS4 version is so emotional.
It is.
I might not get the timing right when it starts, but...
I'm feeling it.
It's so sad.
I think it's now.
Here's to you.
Nicola Embart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you.
Nicola Embart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you.
Nicola Embart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you.
Nikola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you.
The
last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you.
Nikola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony
is your triumph.
Here's to you.
Nikola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you.
Nikola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
Here's to you.
Thank you for a crazy night!